nous sommes le 26 septembre voici le
point sur l'actualité dans les Yvelines
hier soir depuis le rectorat de
Versailles le ministre de l'Éducation
Gabriel Attal a révélé que 120 courrier
de réprobation avait été envoyé aux
parents qui avaient demandé un soutien
au cours de l'année scolaire
2022-2023 55 de ses courriers posent
question cette situation fait suite au
scandale lié au suicide d'un jeune à
Poissy au révélation à d'attouchement
subi par une jeune élève deux affaires
que le rectorat n'avait pas suffisamment
prise au sérieux on appelle un ex
policier a été condamné à 26 ans de
réclusion pour avoir tué son
ex-compagnon de 125 coups de couteau la
cour des Hauts-de-Seine a donc alourdi
sa peine en le déclarant en coupable de
meurtre sur concubin et puis à carrière
sous Poissy le merveille de prendre une
initiative inédite en imposant un arrêté
municipal pour contraindre l'opérateur
XP fibre les habitants se plaignent de
dégradation de coupures et d'armoires
défectueuse l'arrêter imposa xp-fibre de
sécuriser les armoires en 48 heures
spennes d'une amende de 1500 euros